wakanda forever features a villain who
is sometimes an Avenger in the comics
but is that switch really going to
happen in MCU not anytime soon any fan
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe knows
that the script for the Black Panther
sequel changed dramatically after the
death of Chadwick Boseman in August
2020. rumors and Whispers soon surfaced
about potential antagonists for the
revamped black panther wakanda Forever
at San Diego Comic-Con in July 2022 the
antagonist was revealed to be Namor the
Submariner played by Mexican actor
tenoch Huerta introducing Neymar and his
people on the big screen is a huge deal
for Marvel Namor was one of the first
Heroes to ever be published by the comic
book company back in 1939 technically
based on the publication date he's the
first Marvel mutant ever Namor and black
panther also have a complicated history
both have been a significant part of the
Avengers and and the Illuminati comic
history the two Heroes personalities are
similar as well and they often Clash
this makes Namor a great choice for
wakanda forever Kevin feige and Ryan
coogler altered neymore's origin a
little for the film but a lot of who
Namor is as a character remains which
ultimately proves that he isn't ready to
be part of the Avengers just yet in
wakanda Forever Neymar and the people of
telokon start causing trouble when they
kill members of the United States
operation that is searching for
vibranium although they do this out of
protection for their home Neymar's
approach is aggressive even for shuri
and queen raimonda my mother told
stories about a place like this a
protected land with people that never
had to leave
Namor willingly disrespects wakandan
borders to essentially intimidate shuri
and the queen into helping him track
down the scientists that created the
device that could search for vibranium
this happens to be none other than Riri
Williams a genius 19 year old college
student who didn't know that her plans
for such a machine were abused by the US
government
shuri the queen and akoye clearly see
that this is a conflict of morality but
Namor doesn't consider any ethical
repercussions while Namor holds shuri
captive later on and shows her telecon
he explains how their people came to be
out of struggle and Desperation when his
mother died she wanted to be buried back
on land and when he took her there he
saw that the people that were still
there had become enslaved enraged he
killed them all and vowed revenge
against the surface world he tells shuri
that his ultimate goal is to wage war on
the whole of the surface world with
wakanda as their Ally this Vendetta
seems to be namor's driving force in
wakanda Forever the anger built up
inside Neymar ultimately leads him to
kill queen remonda and attack wakanda
toward the end of the film after facing
an incredible amount of loss shuri
herself is more like name more than ever
near the end of the movie too she seeks
out Neymar after becoming the New Black
Panther intending to kill him for what
he did to wakanda and her mother but
ultimately chooses a path similar to her
brother t'challa she makes Namor yield
instead of Killing Him Neymar ultimately
tells the people of telokan to stand
down and return to the Seas this may
have been taken as a gesture of growth
for Neymar but things didn't change much
when Neymar speaks to neymora in the
film's final scene he explains that his
decision was strategic he wants
wakandans to develop empathy for telecon
in the future when they seek allies in a
battle against the surface World Namor
has not overcome his grief and he is far
from joining the surface dwelling
Avengers only time will tell if Namor
will ever join the Avengers as we move
into phase five of the MCU
[Music]